je suis du lorrain je suis mais aux
lorrains mais je connais bien le macumba
et puis qu il y ait pour y avoir non
seulement jouer mais là avoir fréquenté
ces deux communes assez régulièrement
quand j'étais jeune adulte et
l'enseignement qu'attirer de volley-ball
d'abord à la martinique puis en équipe
de france
alors je n'avais pas prévu de partir en
france mais je pense que véritablement
avec toutes les difficultés que j'ai
connues on pourrait dire ne renonce
jamais et j'ai l'impression non
seulement de ne pas avoir renoncé mais
que c'est renoncer non renoncement si on
peut dire ça comme ça
m'ont aidé à vivre une expérience
extraordinaire
cette expérience est ce que aujourd'hui
tu l'a transmis aux jeunes alors
aujourd'hui je
la retraite évidemment mais pendant
quarante ans j'étais ont même plus que
40 ans entraîneur donc j'ai toujours
essayé de faire en sorte que tout mon
vécu soit redonnée à ceux qui veulent
bien les prendre en considération je
suis fanatique de sport fanatiques pas
en tant que supporter je suis convaincu
que le sport quelle que soit la façon de
le pratiquer est quelque chose de
fantastique pour tous tous les
pratiquants et pour toutes les personnes
en général et par conséquent regarder
l'arrivée d'un tour ou d'une étable de
cyclisme
je trouve ça tout à fait naturel est
important et puisque c'est la fête à
macouba aujourd'hui pour l'arrivée je
sais avec de tout cas je me je participe
à cette fête avec les gens de macumba
que j'aime beaucoup qui m'aiment
beaucoup aussi d'ailleurs qui me le
rendent bien
et par conséquent c'est un super moment
que je passe ici au macumba
en regardant bien évidemment l'arrivée
et je dirais effectivement que je n'ai
pas de favori dans le sens où pour moi
le meilleur doit gagner et le meilleur
c'est celui qui arrive à faire toutes
les étapes sans accidents sont
des provisions sa maladie et qui
jusqu'au bout mène sa barque de la façon
la plus efficace possible